what color
skin emoji do you use
if i used one it would be black
why
why not
it's so preposterous all of that
you know everything that's happened to
rogan all this idiocy around race
this insistence that we can be reduced
to our
our race our ethnicity our sexual
identity
it's so appalling and
it's so uh
destructive
in one of the reasons that i
had a lot of reasons for
making my political stance in
relationship to
canada's compelled speech laws i had a
lot of reasons for
making my views about that known
one of them was
the fact that my government had
introduced
a bill that required
me to say things a certain way
which was an unparalleled move in the
history of western democracies and
something the americans had made
strictly unconstitutional i believe in
1942
so that was part of it part of it was i
knew that this
top-down mandated
belief that
confusion around gender identity was
a positive
occurrence
to provide that freedom let's say i knew
that for every person that saved that
would doom a thousand people
primarily girls
to a kind of psychological contagion as
confusion about
sex and gender identity
ramped up
i knew the literature on psychological
contagion uh it was it's what is that
psychological contagion
you could think about them as
psychological epidemics
so the last one the last one of any real
size was the
satanic daycare scares in the 1980s
but you're probably not old enough to
remember that but
the largest longest sentences in u.s
criminal justice history were handed out
often to women who were accused of late
onset female sexual predation of
children in daycare centers
um
the fbi invented a whole new category of
perpetrator category that didn't exist
because there are no late onset female
sexual
child sexual predators
they don't exist
but there were women who obtained prison
sentences of several hundred years for
hypothetically being involved in these
satanic daycare
abuse rituals and there was a it just
swept across the whole country like the
salem witch trials except at a much
larger scale there's a book called satan
silence that was written by
a lawyer and a social worker that
documents it it's just unbelievable
there were stories about
underground tunnels where children were
being taken down and being well every
possible thing you could think of was
happening to them all in the name of
satanic
ritual
it was a contagion
and those things happened it happened
with cutting behaviors
happened with uh eating disorders this
is almost all among girls because their
teenage girls are most prone to this
they called it hysteria back in freud's
time but
there's a book by a man named henry
ellenberger called
discovery of the unconscious that traces
back psychogenic epidemics to about 300
years
and i knew that
you know people
in adolescence especially people of a
certain personality
configuration
um have some trouble settling into a
stable identity and
for a variety of reasons it can be high
negative emotion
which is associated with low self-esteem
those are more or less the same thing
and then in all likelihood high trait
openness which is the creativity
dimension and the high trade openness
people they're the ones that are more
likely to have green hair and red hair
and lots of piercings and lots of
tattoos and dress in a somewhat
in a non
standard manner let's say that's all
associated with creative behavior
and
they have trouble catalyzing a single
identity
and then if you throw in categorical
confusion which is exactly what you're
doing when you declare that there's you
know an endless number of gender
identities then
people who are prone to
identity dissociation and to psychogenic
uh
contagion
they're you're gonna
demolish them there isn't abigail
schreier has documented that quite
nicely in in her book uh
irreversible damage and
it's way more girls than boys and
it's thousands and thousands and
thousands of them so you think well
perhaps a few people who are
transgender benefited from this new
reality but for everyone who's benefited
and you know i'd like to see the data
just showing how much they actually
benefited that'll take a long time to
accrue there's a thousand people who've
been just demolished by this
so and then
what else on the
well that that's basically that on the
political front i could see all that
coming i talked to the canadian senate
about it when they put in the
legislation they didn't listen they just
thought racism bigotry sexism it's like
yeah
have it your way
but you know so what all these girls
that have
rapid onset gender dysphoria and
disfiguring themselves and taking
hormones and
you know wreaking havoc with themselves
and their families and the broader
culture
these people that were so woke and so
permissive you think they're going to
have that on their conscience
they're on to something
some other noble venture
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace